We have three equations here that also supposedly describe the same thing--motion.
But if they all describe the same thing, why do we need three of them?
Well, let's think for a second.
Motion so far seems to involve talking about these five quantities.
How much our position changes, our initial velocity, our final velocity,
our acceleration, and our time.
If we go through each of these equations,
we can see they each involve some combination of these variables.
We can see that this equation involves all the variables except for the final velocity,
this one everything except for change in position,
and this one everything except for time.
These are all going to be useful in different circumstances. Let's do some practice.
Let's say I gave you this situation.
Here we have Galileo again on the top of the leaning tower,
which he may or may not have every done,
and he's going to through a ball downwards at 5 m/s.
Now, the height is 57 m. That's the change in position that the ball is going to have to undergo.
Now, my question is out of these five variables,
which three do we know? And we do know three, not only two.